all right have enjoyed this man's work
on screens large and small from
full-metal-jacket and men in black to
law and order criminal intent and the
Emmy nomination that he earned from
homicide life on the street were both
native New Yorkers and I'm pleased to
have on this show a man who is acting
and directed the movie the kid that's in
theaters this Friday the Western that
also stars his buddy Ethan Hawke and
Chris Pratt good to see you Vincent
D'Onofrio how are you here we we just
saw the the part of the screen uh the
the trailer it's awesome man
congratulations on acts yeah it's it's a
cool movie I have to can I just say
something please room is so guy thank
you good we just wanna have a nice
chills I'm sure everybody says it's such
a boy well it's all it's it's also
filled with a ton of stuff that when I
was fortunate to get this show four plus
years ago my wife would say you know
what that would look good in your studio
instead of the house look bad yeah so
thanks I really appreciate that so you
were fraught you're born in Bensonhurst
right your native New Yorker I am are
you a sports fan of any of the New York
teams not really a big sports fan I
think that's probably strange to hear
it's not a problem
yeah but it's uh I'm I am uh through
osmosis a Jets fan explain this osmosis
to me that it's just because I grew up
watching Namath you know that was like a
big part of my childhood and going
through all his injuries with him and
watching him on the new color TV and you
know it was like a big party he's one of
my you you know because other men's job
I'm hosting the NFL Network I saw him at
the Super Bowl this past year oh cool I
know buddy lights up a room
still like Joe Namath amazing still I
mean yeah oh my gosh everybody who sees
him yeah could not do anything except
stop and I I want to hug him every time
I see him he still is to this day one of
the greatest New York sports athletes of
all time
amazing and certainly one of the
greatest Super Bowl perform
performers of all time for sure you know
I mean I remember them on the sidelines
with like minks I mean coach I mean who
wouldn't want to be that guy right so we
saw a few minutes so you grew up
that's the osmosis you grew up a jet fan
it's only if you don't stick with it or
anything yeah obviously you got a lot of
other endeavors it's going I do I got
persuaded my life got taken by the arts
yeah when did that happen
uh probably right after high school like
when I was about 18 okay yeah right
around then you decided you know what
you wanted to act I decided that I
should study yeah okay to act how old
were you when you were in Full Metal
Jacket I was 24 I tried I tried my best
to not just go straight for the Full
Metal Jacket very good so you were 24
years old yeah how did you get that gig
Matthew Modine was a friend of mine and
he was he was he had started we were we
had met there auditions and class and
stuff like that and then Matthew and I
started working before idea they think
he did like three or four films before I
started working and one day I was I was
working as a doorman at the Hard Rock
Cafe on 57th Street many many years ago
and in the city and he passed by with
his wife and he saw me he came over and
we started talking and he said I'm in
England I'm doing this movie with
Stanley Kubrick I'm like you know wow
that's not a bad name the drop right
there yeah and he said you know there's
a part available and we don't know what
it is but you should probably audition
for it because we're gonna shoot that
later now we're gonna shoot this one
section first and I thought okay you
know like and so he gave me this address
and I made a tape and back then it was a
big deal to make a tape you had the
cameras were like this big you know they
had a pack you had to carry around him
yeah now you just make a youtube link
and you could send it on there's
somebody I mean email audition on their
computers right so we rented this camera
in this in this beta thing and shot a
monologue on I was doing a play at the
time so I shot a monologue from a play
on tenth Avenue and 21st Street and I
sent it out and then I ended up sending
another one they asked for another one
and then Stanley spoke to me and gave me
some words to send out and I sent those
out and the next thing you know he says
um so you'd have to gain
like some wait to come out to play this
part would you be into doing that and
you know DeNiro had just done it for
Raging Bull and I'm like of course the
American director and and I'm I got the
job how much weight you have to put on
well at first we thought 20 or 30 pounds
but I just look like I could kick
everybody's butt hmm so I ended up to be
about 70 pounds before I started looking
weak you know how does somebody put 70
pounds on hash and British food on a
second you mean corned beef hash yeah
okay just wanna make sure okay I just
want to make sure we're talking about
that so that's you just hammered it down
hammered it down yeah what in the world
was it like being directed by Stanley
Kubrick is amazing Vincent D'Onofrio it
was amazing you got a good story
something inspired I do please I do I
have would you like to hear rubella a
rebellious story or a story about actual
events on set
Chris you want to go the opposite way
the set first okay
I'll take either either or if not both
okay um he never spoke about directing
how he was gonna direct he never talked
about character he never talked about
script he never talked about performance
nothing he would just say what are you
gonna do show me what you're gonna do in
Matthew and I would just show him and
he'd say oh it's got to be better than
that yeah I think I'm feeling better
than that so we go back can we think of
something better where it's got to be
faster or slower do this move over there
instead of over there that's how he
directed and um the night before I did
the big scene where I shoot the sergeant
shoot myself he we're leaving and we all
had our cars to go to and as we're
walking he's behind me and I can feel
him behind me and he had this kind of
thing just kind of tic where he would go
before he started to talk every time
Stan Lee Cooper every time like that all
the time so I hear that and I say oh
he's gonna say something to me and he
said and I turned to him and he says um
do you know what you're gonna do
tomorrow and I'm like I think I do
yes I do and he goes okay and I'm
waiting and I'm waiting he says
it has to be big it has to be like lon
chaney big and I'm like okay good and it
was like it was like Christmas like when
you're little I'll tell you why mm-hmm
because as he's saying that to me I'm
thinking about my flat in London and I
have about 30 monster movies VHS is that
I've already rented and bought and had
been watching and most of them were
launched Amy and I'd been studying for
that scene no kidding and it was like
God came down and gave me the biggest
Christmas gift ever and so I called I
you know I called my best friend and I
said dude you know I'm so ready for the
same I couldn't believe it I couldn't
believe it and I went in there and we
did three takes and we were done three
takes text and a special effect yeah
but it was like there's two moments like
that in my whole career that have been
that NSYNC by accident just by luck and
and that's and that's one of them what's
the other the rebellious oh really not
sure I mean I'm interested in hearing is
it um let me tell you the rebellious
story because it's really good go for it
okay so we're all out on these fields
there's like 300 extras they're all
Brits everybody that didn't have a line
is a Brit hmm and so we're all out in
this field out in Becton in the country
in England and there's the giant big
rings of painted yellow tires like
Marine Corps but in big circles and
there's like a hundred guys sitting
around the circles around these tires
and there's three giant circles and
Stanley's up on this crane with his
lenses and he's trying to get a shot and
he's up there up there up there for a
long time
and all these Brits start getting hungry
and they start getting thirsty and they
start getting antsy and and so finally
he's up at the top of the crane and you
hear I can't say it here what can I see
whatever you get blank blank get down
from the crane you know with one of
those thick British accents
and he the thing goes then he turns he
looks at the crowd crane goes down and
the first ad walks over and then the
first day he walks over us who said it
and everybody's like you know come on
guys who said it these look just stop go
back same thing happens again he goes up
on the crane some guy goes get off the
crane we're hungry Bubba so Stanley
comes over this time and he goes um who
said it and there's 300 of us you know
and I'm I'm sitting there and I'm like
I'm not gonna say it either and and and
finally this is true story finally one
of the Brits in the back gets up and
goes I'm Spartacus
and then another guy gets up and goes no
I'm Spartacus I'm Spartacus it was
awesome it was awesome did you finally
get something to eat that's fantastic
Vincent D'Onofrio year and the Rich
Eisen show telling some great tales from
Full Metal Jacket last one for you
earlier me did he did he great guy is it
true that he made all his lines up the
who played the drill sergeant screen did
the thing about that story though that
that's never told is is that he made
them up and Stanley would sit there with
his typewriter and typed them all out
and then Lee would have to repeat them
over and over again so Lee would would
throughout the day make his job harder
and harder his own job harder and harder
because the more he said the more you'd
have to memorize on the spot and shoot
right then so his family was amazing in
that way Stanley used to create
sometimes create the script and create
scenes right in front of you with his
typewriter and it was pretty
extraordinary to watch but yeah Lee Lee
was a pretty amazing - I mean and he was
so amazing in it so are you I mean it's
just an incredible film that it still
sits with me to this day now with you
with the kid and the directing that you
are doing in addition to your acting had
you find yourself doing anything from
Stanley Kubrick or any uh you know those
moments I've been asked that and it's
it's it's really interests
in question cuz you know you don't think
about it until you start directing and
then you realize oh I know this because
of him you know I know this because of
her like all the great people that
you've worked with in your career so
sure you know we were there's some shots
of Dane DeHaan in this movie that a very
Kubrick asked and for sure and you don't
really know you're not conscious of it
until you actually do it and you go oh
my god like I really know a lot from
these people you know these people have
taught me a lot over the years and
you've directed your daughter corrected
Laila George yeah that's amazing in the
movie
I couldn't imagine again my daughter's
five right now she's not a good listener
on occasion what is it like directing
your daughter let's say fantastic she's
she's amazing she's doing really good
her she's got her own career going and
stuff her name is Laila George she
doesn't use our names she just wants to
do it on their own she's fantastic and
you know she she showed up on set every
day well-prepared she has a very
emotional part to play this little
extreme emotion that her character goes
through and she just pulled it off yeah
I was very proud of that's great and
congratulations on that and it's a
Western about a kid who's forced to go
on the run obviously and Chris Pratt
plays a different character for him in
the body a little bad guy yeah and and
Ethan Hawke you've been in tons of films
with him right now yeah right so what do
you like about the Western because it
nobody seems to be making westerns as
much anymore well it's a it's a tough
movie to get made a Western you know
because not everybody likes a Western
you would think that everybody would and
people that like westerns think that
everybody likes westerns but it's not
true and so it's tough for people to put
money behind a Western so you have to
get the right players to come in and do
it and and and hopefully the right
script you know so you know it's a it's
a bit of a task but this particular
thing is a is is is something it's a
coming-of-age story really where I've
taken a fictional character and I've put
him in the middle of two factual
characters packet and Billy the Kid so
this boy goes on
he meets Billy the Kid and then
eventually Pat Garrett and he stays with
them and he's actually there when
Garrett kills Billy and then the story
has it has a has a morale at the at the
end but but I can't say but sure the
it's an intense story about a young
man's point of view of men that have
taught him in his life you know I think
back about my life in the in the the bad
examples that I've had from men and the
good examples that I've had from men
like my stepfather was this incredible
man and if it wasn't for him I wouldn't
be sitting here with you I would be just
some blank head on the street right and
and and but there's other men who I
thought were really super cool but in
fact as a child I never considered the
path of destruction that they're leaving
behind them and couldn't there's
definitely not considering it so the
idea of that that a young boy would have
these two different types of men in
front of him and and grow from that is
the is the keith of story what is your
favorite western if you can pinpoint one
The Searchers I think well his daughter
he didn't stutter right there The
Searchers yeah it's a great movie it is
a great movie I haven't seen in a while
I love I know it's more recent I love
Unforgiven yeah it's really good I think
Unforgiven is just it is it is obviously
Hackman and Hackman form a frame in
those last scenes with him and Hackman
and yeah with Clint Eastwood intact and
I do love Unforgiven do you have a
favorite sports movie Vincent D'Onofrio
hmm I can give you mine for you to kick
start the conversation Hoosiers another
gene movie yeah that's a good movie
where I there's so many times and what I
do for a living and also with my kids
yeah where I will take something from
that film where you measure the rim to
the floor and the baseline of the foul
line yeah
same is this small Jim it just doesn't
matter that you're in the Butler
Fieldhouse and yeah the Annapolis you
know right exact so it's that so many
different ways you can does does does
Brian song still hold that that's course
absolutely I haven't seen it since I was
a kid that was like a huge effect on me
did it really yeah it was the first film
that made me cry like in my life
like that was the like I'd never cried I
thought it was silly like how why would
you cry Brian song
Brian sighs let me cry for the first
time for the first time watching a film
yeah yeah I mean that of course that
still stands in the James Caan and
obviously yeah you know yeah playing
Brian piccolo yeah and you know Gale
Sayers who's uh every now and I see him
with the sit again just to see if it
holds up for me oh sure watch it again
well I mean I've seen Billy Dee Williams
stroll around here but I think you could
still play yeah you could still play a
little bit for sure so Brian song that's
that's a good one um you know obviously
the natural I also love that as well
yeah then that's not a bad film yeah but
I look forward to the kid blowing up for
you sir and I'm a big fan and Sitting
Bull raging you know what I mean it's
not really a sports movie he is oh
here's one for you that I don't think
this is a sports movie and in my world
this is what's called a hot take and I
don't think Rocky's a sports movie right
and we we have asked of Carl Weathers
what he thinks it's a love story yeah
between Adrian yes a love story or maybe
between a guy and boxing how even though
it's it's the environment is a sport its
transcends sport and ties into something
I don't think Rocky's a sports movie
which isn't how it always people say top
five sports movie people think I'm a
little crazy but Raging Bull to me it's
another one of those it's a it's a you
know it's a comment on on on this man's
life yeah oh my gosh yeah in a big way
yeah and it's funny how all that I guess
brings full circle you're like yeah I
can gain some weight for Kubrick yeah De
Niro just did that yeah great to see you
sir thanks for coming much appreciated
and good luck to you the kid in theaters
this Friday on March the 8th check it
out in theaters near you the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience